millions of Americans have already cast
their ballots for the midterms and tens
of millions of more will vote before
November 8th the latest CBS News
Battleground tracker poll shows
Republicans are in a good position to
win a majority of the House Ed O'Keefe
reports on how Republicans and Democrats
are trying to Rally support Ed good
morning
Nate good to see you with just eight
days to go both parties understand they
got to get millions more out to cast
ballots by November 8th and that's why
both parties are drawing out big names
to encourage people to get out and vote
okay guys President Biden alongside
granddaughter Natalie in Delaware
Saturday joining the millions of
Americans voting early and Democrats and
Republicans continue encouraging turnout
amid signs the nation is on edge about
eight in ten likely voters think things
in the country are out of control and
Republicans are winning those who say
that by more than 20 points signaling to
gops poised to take control of Congress
we have a lot in play the Democrat
agenda is very unpopular recent history
suggests the party in power Democrats
could lose big get off your couch and
so both parties spent the weekend
deploying big names in Georgia Michigan
Wisconsin former president Barack Obama
strongly attacked Republicans like
Wisconsin Senator Ron Johnson who's
being challenged by Democrat Mandela
Barnes if he understands giving tax
breaks for private planes more than he
understands making sure that seniors
who've worked all their lives are able
to retire with dignity and respect and
he should not be your senator from
Wisconsin
Democrats also deployed first lady Jill
Biden to New York and Vermont Senator
Bernie Sanders to Texas Republicans are
relying on newer Rising storms Florida
Governor Ron DeSantis up for re-election
himself appears so confident that he
campaigned over the weekend for GOP
candidate Lee Zelda who's running for
New York Governor against incumbent
Democrat Kathy hokel you have the power
to elect Lee zeldin as the next governor
of the state of New York and this will
be the 21st century version of the shot
heard round the world
so those big names are going to be out
on the trail again this week President
Biden is headed tomorrow to Florida
later in the week he goes to New Mexico
former president Donald Trump is also
going to be out on the trail he's
visiting Florida Ohio Iowa and on
Saturday he goes to Pennsylvania that's
the same day former president Barack
Obama is there he's also stopping in
Arizona midweek
Tony
the bigger the names you know the closer
we are Ed thank you very much